absolutely not
these are complex issues that have
technical components technological
components scientific components to
their solution but none of these things
happen if we don't have the
understanding through society what needs
to be done if we don't have the
political and a national will to take
the steps that we have to take if we
don't innovate in the way in which we
organize work as well as organize
Science and Technology it all has to
work together and I'd like to believe
that despite the fact that we look at
these things and look at globalization
as daunting problems they're really
terrific opportunities and at this point
in time no nation on the face of the
globe has a better hand to play than the
United States because we are still the
best particularly at the cutting edge in
science and technology we're
dramatically challenged by other
countries as we should be we're still
the best and unlike much of the world we
build what we do on these remarkable
substrates of a diverse population and a
democracy and an open market system I
believe we've got the best possibilities
in the world of helping to resolve these
problems and providing leadership and
having prosperity in the future but we
can't do it if we don't have the core
science and technology if we don't have
young men and women whether they're
going to be scientists or engineers or
not if we don't have young men and women
who have some technological literacy
some quantitative skills some
understanding of the world at large then
we're going to be in trouble but the
basic answer to your question is
technology alone can never solve these
large-scale problems on the other hand
we can't solve
without